Freddy lures Tina into an alley using a
mysterious voice then after rolling a
trash can LD in her direction to startle
her Reveals His horrifying appearance
arms extended unnaturally to scrape the
wall with his bladed glove Tina's first
reaction is to seek help in God but
Freddy persistently in opposition to
religion mocks her God with his response
please God
this is God he chases her back to the
house demonstrating the ability to warp
around the dream scene slice off his own
fingers with no pain and have his face
torn away remember he's been doing this
for for some time at this point and has
already developed tricks to terrify and
torture his victims using dream logic he
pins her down and slashes her through
the chest before dragging and tossing
her body all around the room